regardez cette carrière imaginez qu'en
1946 se dresse elle a un cratère de 70
mètres le puits de lemptégy faisait
partie des 138 carrière auvergnate
d'extraction de pierres volcaniques
appelé la pouzzolane en creusant c'est
toute la géologie de cet ancien volcan
qui a été mise à nue comme un livre à
ciel ouvert
mais avant de devenir un lieu
touristique la carrière a fourni des
tonnes de pouzzolane 15 mille tonnes par
an soit dix mille aggloméré quotidien
fabriqués par cette usine de la vallée
de la sioule
après guerre les anciens volcans
d'auvergne sont une mine d'or
la pouzzolane et peu chers et sert à
tout alors dans les carrières
on creuse sans penser aux conséquences
sur le paysage
on peut dire que les volcans d'auvergne
sont une sorte de réserve naturelle de
sites classés non moi je suis peut-être
bien d'accord pour certains volcans si
on prenait par exemple le puits de la
vache si on prenait certains puits qui
sont vraiment jolies en faire un peu
dire
enfin je vois pas mes yeux du yacht ou
peint depuis deux volcans par là qu'est
tout propos du représentant non au point
du taux resté que vingt deux sites un
exploitant de carrière n'était pas de
cet avis passionné par les volcans jean
louis montels a réussi à allier
extraction de pouzzolane et conservation
géologique dans sa carrière du volcan de
lemptégy à côté des pelleteuses les
scientifiques sont les bienvenus pour
étudier les roches volcaniques et en
les touristes sont aussi invités à
visiter la carrière qui s'appelle alors
le volcan à celle ouvert en fin
d'exploitation le voeu de l'arrêt de
l'activité des volcans de l'exploitation
dudit volcan c'était des recours here
avec de la terre j'ai trouvé cela très
choquant on lui demande si cela
nécessite pour lui pas question de
reverdir le site et de gommer le passé
d'extraction
mais au contraire laisser la carrière
tel quel pour que les touristes puissent
déambuler dans le coeur du volcan est
une initiative extrêmement
extraordinaire aux tchèques bien pour le
professionnel que je suis que pour le
grand public qui est une chose nous
retirer pour le volcanisme les années
passent
association carrière d'un côté et lieux
touristiques de l'autre fonctionne et le
volcan de lemptégy devient une affaire
familiale parce que vous voyez ici c'est
l'intérieur du volcan
et c'est effectivement grâce à
l'exploitation de la carrière depuis une
cinquantaine d'années qu'on a découvert
tout l'intérieur nombreux plants au
milieu des années 2000 l'activité
d'extraction s'arrête et le site devient
un lieu entièrement dédié au tourisme et
à la pédagogie autour du volcan
petit train mine souterraine animation
en 3d spectacle pyrotechnique
les visiteurs sont conquis si on à
celles découvertes on voit on voit c'est
réel c'est la réalité alors que dans une
exposition on voit des petites pierres
ou à des choses comme ça et on n'arrive
pas à s'imaginer ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer ici aujourd'hui le volcan de
lemptégy attire tous les ans près de 120
mille visiteurs une carrière réhabilité
en musée à ciel ouvert
[Musique]